both of you are optimists you ever have
doubts about that or is it just your
both your nature is just the press on it
I don't you spend too many days in
Washington DC you can have brief moments
where you wonder is this system this
works so well for hundreds of years
somehow hit a rut but in general no I'm
very optimistic I mean we've got
innovation you know whether it's new
vaccines new seeds new ways of
delivering things conductivity and even
in education the glimmer of you've got
people in Rwanda trying out MOOCs to see
if they work and there's their situation
and it'll take a decade of refinement
but the pace of innovation is faster
today than ever and so you can be
impatient about getting it out there but
nothing's really taken away my optimism
the whole history of humanity is just
one long battle between conflict and
cooperation and between us and them and
basically we're here today because we
kept expanding the definition of us
whoever the US was in shrinking the
definition of them so yeah this is tough
now but we've had a lot of periods of
you know bitter conflict and there's a
lot of complex psychological identity
questions in American politics today
aggravated by this loan stagnant economy
for most people but if we will get
through it and the trajectory is still
good